[Music]
good morning welcome to sky
news breakfast thank you for joining us
the prime minister has called a summit
with the leaders of the devolved
administrations in scotland wales and
northern ireland
saying the uk is best served when we
work together
it comes after the first minister of
scotland warned him not to block her
push for a second scottish independence
referendum
the snp leader said boris johnson would
be picking a fight with the democratic
wishes
of the scottish people if he tries to
stop another independence vote
let's take a look at the breakdown of
the scottish election results
the snp fell one short of an overall
majority winning 64 seats
the conservatives won 31 labour 22
and the liberal democrats four there is
a majority for pro-independence parties
though as the scottish greens won eight
seats
our political correspondent joe pike
reports from aberdeen
nicola sturgeon secured the fourth snp
term she wanted
but not the majority she craved
yeah that's not stopping a push for
another independence vote
it is a commitment made to the people
by a clear majority of the msps who have
been elected
to our national parliament it is the
will
of the country and given that outcome
there is
simply no democratic justification
whatsoever for boris johnson or indeed
for anyone else
seeking to block the right of the people
of scotland
to choose our own future
in an attempt to pacify and placate the
smp
boris johnson has written to nicolas
sturgeon offering to talk
he writes i would like to invite you to
join me
uk government colleagues and others at a
summit meeting to discuss our shared
challenges
and how we can work together in the
coming months and years to overcome them
i will be writing in similar terms to
the first minister of wales
and the first and deputy first ministers
of northern ireland
elsewhere khan remains mayor of london
in a contest
closer than expected the results of the
elections around the
uk show that our country
and even our city remain deeply
divided so as we now seek to confront
the enormity
of the challenge ahead and as we
endeavor
to rebuild from this pandemic we simply
must use this moment of national
recovery
to heal those damaging divisions
other prominent mayors were also
re-elected conservative andy street in
the west midlands
and labour's andy burnham in greater
manchester
in wales mark drakeford kept his job and
credited that win to his government's
covert 19 response
now the counting is over in scotland at
least
among the losers the country's former
first minister alex salmond
he had a rare taste of defeat as his
alba party failed to win
a single seat but dividing lines remain
here
and the path ahead is chopping
at this scottish election turnout was up
and tactical voting was too
in particular pro-union scots backing
the party with the best chance of
beating the
smp but today scotland remains split
on the central issue of independence and
it's almost
50 50. this country's constitutional
journey
is still far from over joe pike sky news
aberdeen
meanwhile labour's deputy angela rayner
has been sacked from her roles as party
chair and campaign coordinator following
the party's poor results
in the english local elections it has
created conflict within the party with
greater manchester mayor andy burnham
already saying he doesn't support
kierstama's decision
political correspondent rob powell is in
westminster for us this morning and
robert
also a few of the papers pointing to a
civil war
within labor that that's erupting now
yeah and i think what will maybe be
concerning for
the labour leadership and secure star
majillian is that yes there is a lot of
criticism and the most vocal criticism
um about the sacking of angela rayner as
campaign coordinator and party chair
a lot of that is coming from people that
were close to jeremy corbyn the former
leader people on the left wing of the
party
but the criticism isn't exclusively
coming from that side of the party
you just mentioned andy burnham not
agreeing with this move he's hardly
someone
that can be said to be a corbinista
but i think what they share is the
concern
that the story of these elections for
labor seems to be a story of them
failing
to cut through um in areas in the north
of england
in working-class areas so to make your
first move
after uh to sack someone who
is a mp for the north of england that
grew up there and that is a
one of the most senior working class
women in the party
that is why eyebrows are being raised
and people are saying that she should be
given
more of a focus rather than less now
those in kisstama's office are saying
uh that there still will be a role for
angela rayner
going forward that she still will have a
prominent role to play
but i think given that kierstama said
that he takes responsibility for this
and that he takes responsibility for
changing the party
many within labor uh are wondering
whether change should really start
from the top uh and whether sakira
stamina should maybe look a little bit
closer to home as well
rob thank you well we now have plenty of
results in from across britain with the
conservatives making gains in
england labour holding on in wales and
the snp storming ahead
in the hollywood elections joining me
now to discuss some of those results the
former strategic adviser to jeremy
corbyn james
mills good morning to you and first of
all what do you make of this um
sacking of angela rainer in her two
roles as um
campaign coordinator and party chairman
to be honest i think it's daft and
uncalled for i mean i've worked with
angela rainer
she's a very good campaigner i don't
think you could in a million years tie
the results that happened to her um
these things tend to be collective
decisions i mean
let's be honest these local election
results are the worst we've had since
2008.
um the idea that it's one person is for
the birds it's not one person's fault
there should be a review
of how we've performed and that should
be written in branch reform
across our methods of funding uh how
we're
actually going and campaigning there's
lots of things for example i was calling
for
where's our where's our postal vote
strategy in these elections which is a
bit of a no-brainer given the fact that
there'll be a surge
in postal votes i didn't see that very
well communicate i don't think there
really was one and i'm speaking as
someone who's
worked in politics can tell when you
there is a coherent one and i didn't see
it whereas i could see the tories and
even the s p
seem to have one and look on the on this
whole issue that today we should be
talking about
so the results of friday run were
terrible for later they're absolutely
terrible
but we should have been talking about
today but it has been some strong
performances you've seen
well i live in greater manchester andy
berm re-elected the landslide
we've picked the toys to the post and
came between peter and their ortiz
we've won the west of england uh mayoral
election we've
great performances in liverpool bristol
and london there are some things that
kiersten could be pointing today
and talking up and i actually think it's
a bit of an insult to the members
uh activists and staff who have been
working really hard to get those results
because yes these are bad results we
have some positive things instead
we're descending into a debate this
morning about the civil war and the
labour party which is uncalled for and
should not be happening and i
you know i can't defend it i don't think
anyone's serious can defend it and i
think it's managed to unite the labour
party ironically from all its wings
uh anger at this decision overnight uh
joining us sir
for this debate now former conservative
special adviser anita
buateng uh morning to you um there are
those that
say that really the success of the
conservatives
isn't down to anything that they've done
in particular but rather
it's the failings of labor that that
people have been responding to what
would you say to that
i think that what we are seeing is the
conservative party being rewarded for a
record of delivery
this is really about the investment that
the country
has seen from the conservatives
particularly in areas
um you know in the t side area where
we've seen investment by the towns fund
and we've got you know the darlington
campus moving up north i think these are
all really positive
signals to the country the government is
very serious about us leveling up agenda
and that is what the country has
endorsed in these set of local
and mayoral elections not about
punishing labour
no i think labour's lack of appeal is a
decade-long problem that it's not it's
failing to grasp
and there is an issue with the fact that
kierstama certainly isn't cutting
through and convincing the country
that labour has really changed i mean i
was really struck by mandelson's
comment that the history of the labour
party in elections has been
lose lose lose blair blair blair lose
lose lose lose
and its failure to reckon with that
reality is why it is failing to appeal
but nevertheless the conservative
strength is what has delivered this set
of election results
james you want to come in there yeah i
heard that thing from mandelson look
people forget
that peter madison was running the 2010
uh general election for gordon brown so
but peter mandelson is is outdated i
mean the last time he won something
there weren't smartphones or social
media i think but he did he did manage
to keep hartley pool though
yeah tywin labour was doing really well
i mean i think we could have won a
harley pool
regardless of where peter mandelson was
there and to be totally honest i think
that in a nutshell sums up the the
ridiculousness and the poor
communications
during this campaign we went on a issue
of sleaze
and then we had peter mandelson on the
doorstep and was campaigning with him
whose track recommendation is actually
not very strong in this area
now my i i'll turn around and i'd flip i
think we'd perform really poorly i think
our strategy going these local lectures
was
anonymous our communications were
terrible we didn't have a clear message
we started on the nhs
and we effort and we veered off over
everything else never came back to it
we couldn't answer very clearly a simple
question about how our positional nurses
pay
and whether the toys are delivered i
think it flatters the tories to be
totally honest i don't think they're
doing a particularly good
job i think they're getting a bit of a
balance yes from the the cove
the vaccination broke out which was led
by the nhs but you you
i've been on council stage the past few
weeks and i've been across there many
different areas
and i'll tell you that i've been getting
a lot of people very upset they're very
worried about the future to worry about
the economy about public funding for
public f public services
and what the prospects are ahead i don't
necessarily think that
there's um let's just say that they're
overwhelmed with the conservatives i
think the problem is they're waiting for
labour to turn up and offer us a good
vision and alternative
for the future and i think that's what
they need to do over the next few months
anita do you think there's some some
some truth in that there has been as the
the many of the papers have described it
that the vaccination bounce the
the boris bounce because we are in a
pandemic it's very difficult for
an opposition to to disagree with with
what the the prime minister and the
government are spearheading
i think that it's a vaccination bounce
so use this phrase i think it's a little
glib
when you consider the level of success
and the difference that the government's
regime and rollout
has made to this country and to saving
literally thousands if not
millions of lives and that is not
guaranteed and we've seen the record
across europe that actually this is a
very challenging program
to to execute well and i think james
really talks down the success
and the effort that has gone into
delivering that not just from nhs staff
but also
from ministers that have overseen the
rollout of this system
i also want to pick up on this point but
james i'm sure he has been on a couple
of council states over the past few
weeks
i am canvassing every single weekend and
have been doing so since it's illegal to
do so in my patch where i'm a councillor
and what i can tell you is yes voters
are concerned about the future
they aren't concerned about the economy
they are concerned about recovery from
covert
and what they see is that the
conservatives offer a better path
a buildback greener path that does
naturally appeal
and what we saw in the west midlands
what we saw with andy street
is that this focus on investment on
tangible benefits
for the region is what's really been
rewarded just allowed james to
come back in there i've been on a couple
of council states and also for
i'm a kid from a council state just so
you know where am i
background and you know it's to be
brilliant
it's not like some something i don't
notice i'll tell you what also they've
seen happening to working people in the
government politics with
the fine rehire where people for working
class people right now
who work in some very sort of
working-class jobs i've seen their terms
conditions destroyed
and the government might have their
thing on it they're seeing that to pay
frozen not just in the last few years
but over the last 10 years and then it's
the government the thing on it so i
don't necessarily think it's as razor
you think
and look you don't say there's a vaccine
bounce look at the poles you can see
about
before the vaccine was bounced at labour
actually ahead and where you've seen the
real decline has been from this i don't
think you can rule out that
vaccine bounce but i'm not trying to
just justify the load by this run
really poor campaign let's take a look
now at the other stories making the news
this morning at least
58 people believed to be mostly female
students have died in an explosion close
to a school in the afghan capital kabul
more than 150 others were also
reportedly injured in the blasts
which the country's president ashraf
ghani has blamed on the taliban
who have denied responsibility
at least 80 people have reportedly been
injured outside the old city of
jerusalem during a second night of
violence
as tensions continue to soar over the
threatened eviction of palestinians in
the sheikh jarrett neighborhood
israeli police on horses and in riot
gear fired stun grenades and water
cannon at crowds
while palestinian protesters threw
stones tens of thousands of muslims
attended prayers yesterday marking
lailat al-khadiri the holiest night
in the month of ramadan
three people including a four-year-old
girl have been injured
after being shot in a fight that broke
out in new york's times square
police say the child who was shot in the
leg and two other victims both women
are expected to survive
rail passengers could face days of
disruption after cracks were found on a
number of high-speed trains
hitachi 800 trains were pulled from
lines yesterday as a precautionary
measure
with great western railway and london
north eastern advising people
not to travel today
time to take a look at the weather now
with isabelle and it is much nicer than
it was yesterday isn't it i know
it's really nice yeah i mean it did get
to about 18 degrees we were so close to
the really warm air over in france
where temperatures were into the low 20s
you know but we are tapping into that
again today across the
south east and east anglia i should
think temperatures could comfortably
reach around 21 or 22 degrees
very nice indeed let's take a look at
the whole picture though
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
yeah an absolutely stunning day actually
across the near continent and we have
seen one or two thunderstorms actually
just creeping into the channel affecting
kent this morning
that's in the warmer air they'll move
away quite quickly this morning then i
should think across east anglia in the
southeast today
it'll be mostly fine through daylight
hours with temperatures into the low 20s
now elsewhere well
as you can see we've got low pressure
which is the main trigger for the
showers across northern and western
areas blustery winds coming up from the
south
some heavy showers expected and we still
got the remnants of yesterday's rain
particularly through the midlands and up
into south yorkshire and lincolnshire
that zone of cloud
should gradually thin and break and
hopefully it'll turn just a little bit
drier and brighter there to end the day
so these are the sort of temperatures 15
through the central part of scotland
20 to 22 in the southeast but just watch
for another area of showers to brew up
across france they could well
move into southeastern parts of the
country during this evening and
overnight and eventually tomorrow they
can well
push up into northeast scotland
otherwise tomorrow a repeat performance
sunshine and showers
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
nicholas sturgeon is making her move
towards a new referendum vote
saying that no uk government should
stand in the way of the democratic
rights of the scottish people
but what's the appetite amongst voters
for another bout of constitutional
wrangling scotland correspondent james
matthews reports
it will take some working out after the
election
what now for the timing and tempo of a
campaign
for independence so the overall can i
think happening in england
is not really what scotland wants to
have a conservative government is there
a bigger difference now are we just
different from the rest of the uk do you
think
i don't think it's a different as such
we just believe in different things i
voted
snp but i'm not quite ready to go
through the whole
yes vote again i think that tore all the
country apart
this was the yes campaign in 2014
in a referendum endorsed by a british
prime minister after an snp majority
in a scottish election blair jenkins led
that yes campaign
what does he say now i would accept that
right now
it's about 50 50 in terms of people
being for independence or against
independence that's obviously from uh
from a yes point of view that's a very
good starting point it's a much better
starting point than it was back in 2012
when the last campaign started
with a focus already on a referendum
when
how and what if boris johnson blocks it
how do pro-india
msps who relish change realize it
i think both sides really have a
responsibility to look
afresh at the economic case both for
independence
and for the union and you know those who
those who want to suggest that that
brexit britain is a
is a good place where scotland can
thrive and become a
fairer more equal and greener society i
think they have the harder job in their
hands
dumbarton rock was a hard place for the
snp
it lost a titanic struggle with labour
for the marginal dumbarton seat
if there was a red wall in this election
this was it
and it needs rebuilt what labour needs
to demonstrate
in all of our work at hollywood is that
we can deliver that better
fairer society with the powers that the
scottish parliament has got
as snp supporters are quick to point out
david cameron delivered
brexit after an election in which he won
a share of the vote
far lower than the snp have at this one
it's a discussion that's exercised this
country through 14 years of snp
government
and counting james matthews sky news
glasgow
let's talk some more now about where
scotland goes next
we're joined from andrews by the former
snp
mp stephen geffens and from inverness by
the former conservative
snp mary scanlon good morning to you
both uh first of all stephen gephind to
you um
we we know that nicholas sturgeon has
missed her dearest wish
that overall majority does it therefore
mean that she doesn't have the mandate
that uh she said she would require
to go for a second independence
referendum
of course not and i think you're sort of
comparing two different things of course
at the westminster
system you look at majorities which are
delivered on a minority
of votes but in this election the snp
has won and you have a pro-independence
majority in parliament you the snp
took more constituencies than have ever
been taken before the higher share of
the votes that have ever been taken
before
and i think in about 48 of the vote and
bear in mind boris johnson is making
radical changes to the united kingdom
and her relationship with europe to the
extent of even talking about no deal
brexit
on his thumping majority of 80 based on
about 42 and a half percent
of the vote it's a parliamentary
democracy the same rules apply
nicholas sturgeon won and she won well
the snp won and she won well
what normally happens in the aftermath
of a win as you talk about implementing
the winners manifestos
uh mary scanner nasty even getting says
that there is a
pro-independence party majority uh now
does that therefore mean that we will
see
a second referendum on independence in
your view
well it's interesting gettings talks
about uh
implementing the manifesto the manifesto
is to try and address our
very poor and declining education system
the worst drug deaths in the whole of
europe and
people having to wait over six years for
orthopedic surgery
all of a sudden we've hardly wakened up
from the results
and the independence referendum is top
of the agenda
can i just say i've been over 40 years
in the scottish conservatives
i've been through mrs thatcher the poll
tax you name it
and i've never known anything so
divisive
so so tearing the country apart as much
as another referendum
and i was with envy i have to say when i
listened to the labour
first minister for wales yesterday and
all credit to him
talking about working together uh
talking about a stable and progressive
government
and if only we had that in scotland
we've got
five years of divisiveness
confrontation picking battles with
westminster
it's really quite depressing when you
look at the public services that are
declining david you want to come in on
that
yeah i mean i think mary's fighting the
old battles of the election there look
what you do the day you you fight these
battles during an
election and we held out all heard all
these awful stories from the
conservative party remember in terms of
domestic policy the snp is most trusted
um in terms of in terms of education
in terms of health all these other other
areas nicola sturgeon
not only was it most trusted in the
polls but was actually endorsed in an
election and we're in the aftermath of
an election so i think
she's right in one sense that you move
on and you look at what did the winning
party
seek to do and in terms of whether or
not there's a mandate i don't think you
can count green votes as being somehow
anti-independence there's an
independence majority
and mary raised the welsh first minister
who said of course
you know if scotland votes to have an
independence referendum it should have
an independence referendum so mary's
trying to fight these old arguments what
you do after an election is you look at
the results you'll look at what the
people have said
and you implement that and that's the
way our democracy
works whether some of us like it or not
i don't like the fact we're being
dragged out of the eu
against our will it didn't like the 42.6
delivering that tory
majority but it's what we've got but
scotland could choose something
different in fact not only can it choose
something different
it chose something different a couple of
days ago
but these are not old arguments stephen
a government
is elected to govern not just to pick
battles within the united kingdom it's
elected to represent the people
it's elected to help the ladies in
inverness who tell me
they have to wait six years to get a hip
replacement we've already been through
four years of tortuous tortuous
negotiations with europe it would be ten
times worse trying to vote
actually i sat
please focus on the people and the
public services
and i mean life i can't nicholas just
work with boris johnson
if i can if i can come in if i can come
in there assuming you're saying it
should be about
uh the policies going forward and
looking to the future what i wonder what
you make
of uh boris johnson's um calling of
a devolved summit the the letter that's
been written inviting and nicolas
sturgeon and the other
uh first ministers to to talk about the
future and working together
is that something you welcome well look
first of all if i could just deal with
one of the things that mary said and i
think this is important over the coming
days nicholas sturgeon will appoint
education ministers health ministers
transport ministers
finance ministers all the ministers who
have got the jobs of getting on with the
job in government and of course
people in scotland think that nicola
sturgeon and the snp government has been
doing a much better job the
conservatives have been doing
if they didn't and they wouldn't have
elected the smp and overwhelmingly
rejected
the conservatives now many might not
like that and that's fine and that's
mary's opinion and she'll have voted
a different way in terms of boris
johnson well he's not done an awful lot
you know
when it came to things like cop26 and
trying to engage
on that i can remember being at
westminster when the that when we
as a group at westminster try to engage
with the conservatives about making
brexit better and i was part of a
cross-party
coalition who managed to get legislation
done but
any idea of cross-party talks around
making that better
were overwhelmingly rejected the tories
decided to work with the dup
and put money into northern ireland
again as part of that governing
and coalition that they pulled together
so if boris johnson wants to talk
that's fine talk and let's see what he's
got to say mary but his track record
isn't terribly good you're not trying to
look forward
stephen you've accused me of talking
about the past try and look forward
we're in a united kingdom
let's work together let's put the people
first
let's put health education the worst
drug deaths 14 years of snp
failure let's work together in scotland
but across the united stand mary scanlan
and stephen i'm afraid we must leave it
there we'll end on that uh
positive note from mary then working
together for the future we shall see if
that
happens
a surge in demand for beer post lockdown
has offered a glimmer of hope for the
struggling
pub industry but the demand has also led
to shortages of the alcoholic beverage
with breweries increasing their
production in a bid to meet the demand
and north of england correspondent tom
parmenter reports
you only get good beer by being
meticulous
but if we don't put it in a totally
clean path all that great work is ruined
after the worst year possible and losses
of 1.3 million pounds
the timothy taylor's brewery in keithley
is now battling to keep up with demand
last weekend for the first time since
1858 they brewed on a sunday
but you know if i tell you the last two
weeks we've done similar volumes to what
we did
in the same two weeks in 2019 so that's
you know uh unbelievable against that
forecast that people gave us
i just think there's loads of pent-up uh
demand particularly amongst those who
don't like braving the cold so
when it goes indoors i think it'll bring
out a whole other you know group of
consumers
they may not have quite as much
tradition but at this micro brewery in
an old tram shed in saltire
they're also seeing sales at
pre-pandemic levels
even without their indoor space open
it's so good in fact that some premium
mainstream lagers
are now being rationed by their
suppliers i'm surprised that they're
running out already
very much for you certainly the second
time i've come out but to actually have
like a pulled pint
it's been really nice you just can't get
it anywhere else can you
i missed it i don't you know yeah it's
not embarrassing
but i haven't missed it i think you've
missed the social security yeah and the
social sector
than anything there are many hospitality
businesses that just haven't made it
this far
or are still waiting to reopen but the
need for people to reconnect
socially is strong cheers and it's been
freezing cold at night and
you know i couldn't imagine sitting
outside and the bay garden's been full
of people you know blankets coats
uh the same with the rain in the hail um
and i think that's the the one message
we'd like to send from the brewery is
you know thank you to the british public
for kind of
braving the elements and returning to
the pub the big brewers say the supply
problems
will be rectified it is a problem but in
the context of kovid
it is a good problem to have tom
parmenter
sky news west yorkshire
i'm not going to say anything about the
beer because it might be misunderstood
the problem is whenever there's a story
about beer now we're all talking about
well we are listening to the package
obviously with tom parmenter but we're
also chatting about alcohol
which is the problem because we all get
a bit excited drinking outside in the
sun
i know a possibility yeah we can sit
outside today
uh can we all well some of you might
need a brolly
but that's fine yeah my brother last
week um had fish and chips with hail
stones in it
um because he lives in the highlands and
today you could have similar sort of
thing let's take a look
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
so we are still looking pretty unsettled
we had low pressure yesterday the low
itself not quite as deep as it was so
the weather perhaps not quite so gusty
but there will still be showers around
it will drive in showers with this
southerly breeze as well
the heaviest i should think today will
be across ireland and northern ireland
and running up into scotland a few
across western areas of england and
wales
now across most central parts of england
this morning it's quite damp
the cloud will gradually shift eastwards
but it'll probably break up a little bit
and then ahead of that across east
anglia in the southeast it's
warm 20 to 22 degrees that's where it
really will feel very nice this
afternoon but just if you're out late
bear in mind that there will be some
thunderstorms
this evening and the theme stays pretty
shary throughout the
next few days but at least less frosty
by night which is good news
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
with us now to take us through the
newspapers the parliamentary sketch
writer and
telegraph columnist madeline grant and
the political editor of the sunday
mirror
nigel nelson welcome back to you both
starting with you uh first of all
madeline and having a look at the
observer online in this instance and the
re-election of
sadiq khan as a mayor of london perhaps
a closer-run
race than than people had predicted with
sean bailey for the conservatives doing
a lot better than people thought
yes that's exactly right even though
sadiq khan has now won by
i think around 55 to 45 of the final
tally
as you say his victory was a lot less
convincing than many predicted
um and the guardian reports that there
was a big late surge in support for sean
bailey
um but it's very interesting to note
because there were polls
um until pretty recently giving um sadiq
khan as much as the 25 point lead
um so there may be an element of a
failure of polling here but
i think it does also make you wonder
what the tories might have achieved
in london if they hadn't run such a
half-hearted campaign and perhaps chosen
somebody
um more of a political heavyweight for
their candidate you know it wasn't
um it wasn't actually very long ago that
the tory bosses were busy withdrawing
funds
from the campaign and scaling back his
team
to a kind of skeleton crew because they
they genuinely thought it was a
a no hoper um so perhaps this tells us
that there was
um perhaps a greater level of
dissatisfaction with sadiq khan
than men realized and also that that shy
toys can be found everywhere
even in london shy tourism i like that
description
uh the male nigel they're looking at
them this is interesting as
andy burnham being tipped for the next
labor
leader not that that contest has been
started but
no indeed no it hasn't yet um but yes i
mean
uh he more or less sort of ruled himself
in yesterday
um didn't say he was going to challenge
kia starmer but he said if the call came
from uh labor to uh for a new leader
uh he might rise to the challenge oh i
thought i thought actually because he
spoke to sophie ridge i thought he
actually ruled himself out
and that he was saying that he would
help he would help labor
but it wasn't something he was thinking
about because he was so enjoying his
role
as mayor of greater manchester that's
right he's not he's not talking about
challenging kierstarma now
he's he's talking about not ruling out a
challenge
should kierstama go and uh this clear
has probably got another year really to
actually pull things around
otherwise he probably will go my own
feeling is that the
the next labour leader almost certainly
has to be a woman the labour party has
never had one
so i would see someone like yvette
cooper or rachel reeves being more
likely
but andy may well have a go uh he's lost
twice before he lost when miliband in
2010
and jeremy corbyn in 2015. so you never
know third time lucky
we shall see to uh scotland uh nicola
sturgeon
uh vowing to um continue with her
drive towards a second independence
referendum this is in the observer
madeline
yes and i would say that this is uh this
is really more of a kind of
a dog bites man story than a man bites
dog um
it's entirely predictable that nicola
sturgeon has called for another
independence referendum
on the basis that the snp won the holy
ruled elections
but you know i would argue that it's not
at all obvious where this mandate comes
from and it's not just the case that the
snp failed to secure
the overall majority that alex salmon
for example managed to achieve in 2011
and that formed the basis for
much of their um their mandate for the
2014
referendum um but also the pro-unionist
parties narrowly edged the elections
getting just over 50
of the vote so i think and given also
that the snmp deliberately
tried to as little as possible about the
prospect of indirect
during the election campaign because
they knew that um that the prospect was
quite a
turn off for floating voters i think to
reignite it now and so
soon after the event um seems seems like
very unscrupulous behavior though i
don't think it should
should come as a surprise to anyone
who's been um interested in events north
north of the border nigel to the express
a completely different story we've all
sort of got used to
our online consultations with uh gps and
medical professionals but but this is
looking at the fact that doctors are
being told now to start
seeing patients face to face again yes
that's right and the royal college of
gps
um will produce a report this coming
week
on telemedicine and what the future it
is i do think that after
the pandemic um the whole of society
will need some kind of reset
so uh the economy is going to be changed
our working practices are obviously
changing
uh we'll probably be re-looking at how
benefits are paid for instance
same thing applies to applies to
medicine
and one of the things that i think that
the pandemic has shown
is you can quite effectively do online
consultations with your gp
so even if you do an e-consult you can
just put in a load of questions
which is more or less what the gps use
themselves to work from
uh outline your symptoms it allows you
to say
things you might have forgotten if you
were doing it face to face
the important thing then is it should be
only a triage system
so yes let's have have more remote
consultations
but the moment it looks like there is
something which needs a face-to-face
appointment
make sure the gp gives it yes zoom
working in some
cases in in the world of medicine and
but not so for magicians in the
telegraph madeline
yes i really love this story because um
you know we're all struggling to adapt
to the new normal as best we can but
um here is an example of a profession
that i hadn't really considered
um it's about magicians and how they are
struggling to adapt with giving their
performances on
zoom and streaming platforms because
it's all filmed
it means that um viewers have a much
better chance or could have
of of spotting the the secrets of of the
magician code you know how they perform
their tricks
so the magicians are reportedly having
to work twice as hard to
prevent the um the bd-eyed viewer from
potentially unraveling their secrets hmm
what why is it why are you more likely
to see the tricks on on zoom than you
would on a normal
program i think it's just that you could
you could whiz it back and keep watching
and often that their
tricks rely on sleight of hand and
people being distracted
and that is much easier to carry off in
person
um particularly if you're on a stage
with lights and so on i think the zoom
would
just bring the view of that closer and
giving me a chance to watch it multiple
times
and i guess it's a tighter shot on zoom
uh
vegetables nigel
small this is a new idea where you can
rent someone's garden
uh to grow your own veg at the moment
allotments are very hard to come by
so it all started off with somebody uh
someone in london who
uh put a bot a pot of basil on their
window screen on their window
then they wanted to grow onions and
potatoes and had nowhere to do it
so uh what what he did was was then rent
a neighbor's garden
this is now growing and there's going to
be a digital platform launched this week
which basically
is to link up people who love vegetables
with people who've got unloved garden